[Music]
let us talk about this Means War
I saw the movie last night with a bunch
of people from my office people were
howling it's a very funny movie oh yeah
we had a great time making it it was
just like every day we were making up
the scenes and the lines and we just
threw it all in there there's a it's a
really funny idea but there's a
silliness to it and a lightness and and
Tom Hardy Chris Pine he's two very
good-looking guys are vying they're both
trying to win you over right they're
both spies yeah but you know it's sort
of in this heightened world where they
decide they they want to settle down and
find a woman to spend their lives with
and then they some for some reason fall
in love with the same woman and then
they decide they're gonna kill each
other over her yes and they use they use
everything at their disposal tactics and
spying techniques - yeah it's very well
done it's a great idea and really funny
and there's a there's a scene that had
me howling I just Tom Hardy's character
takes you paintball shooting paintball
guns and he takes it way too seriously
and I was watching the scene I was just
curious
are you comfortable around guns do you I
used someone that grew up with guns yeah
I mean I grew up in Tennessee so pretty
much everybody has a gun I'm not kidding
yeah you show up in second grade like
everyone had your gun over yeah so the
way before we start shooting it was the
first day of shooting and they said we
just want to make sure you're okay with
guns like I am okay with guys there no
we really need you to practice so they
showed up all these targets and I just
shot them all
Wow okay I can see the gun so well it
comes you know naturally my
sister-in-law is like a national
Tennessee National Rifle reach champion
yes yeah so I sort of get it by marriage
yeah that's good
this has got to be a dream role for any
actress you've got two of these amazing
looking guys who are fighting over you
and you must have when you heard the
concept for the movie you must have said
this is yes this to be good I like this
this one yes I will take that picture
yes sir I may show up for work for that
yeah it was exciting and I'm also so
excited work with Chris Pine and Tom
Hardy who in my opinion are just on the
precipice of huge careers they're both
so talented and great we have a great
chemistry together they're very funny as
friends yeah they're so funny and they
have there's a great guy friendship at
the center of the movie and then there's
a great girl friendship between myself
and Chelsea Handler's so it's it's got a
lot of stuff in it well I I mentioned
this to you before the show but I was
watching it and like in like an idiot I
didn't know who directed it so the
movies just ending and I said he's
really good he's gonna do well this
director he's an up-and-comer and then
it said directed by Nick G you know I
was like oh I'm an idiot
you know he's fantastic he's made a few
movies but it's really good we have a
clip here what do we need to know for
this well this is um one of the dates
and Chris pines take me on a date and
Tom Hardy has put his sort of secret spy
skills on the date and so he starts to
interfere yes he breaks in to screw up
his game let's take over this clip from
This Means War this is incredible
are these real yeah you recognize this
yes 95 look at the tension between the
two and three dimensionality the tension
between the two and three dimensionality
it's incredible this is my favorite
thing
Undine 1902 Undine 1902
amazing innovation became intrinsic
today God on the other modernist you
know he was a strong advocate of the
finger-painting movement right we lost
contact sometimes he would finger his
paintings to get the intimacy with a
canvas dude to finger a painting
sometimes he would use mud sticks you
know he used mud in sixth and if he
couldn't find a stick and if you
couldn't find a stick you just used what
[Applause]